we are here in Washington DC to extend
the college's mission we teach our
students who come from Hillsdale College
to the Kirby Center as a campus we teach
congressional staff that come to our
various programs the public that come to
our lectures we teach members of
Congress on a regular basis we talk to
them who spend time with them we help
them write and think the space here is
also unique in Washington DC in that
it's a place that members of Congress
staffers for members of Congress people
from all walks of life can come together
and get a piece of the Hillsdale
experience in Washington DC the Kirby
Center offers a way to really draw in
these other these other branches of
conservatism to really think about what
do we believe and how do we emphasize
those principles how do we educate
ourselves to continue that process one
of my objectives when I came here was to
make it active place lively an activity
students hear on a regular basis we have
monthly lecture series which are high
profile intellectual thinkers inviting
actual statesmen current practitioners
the art if you will first one was
Senator Marco Rubio from Florida
followed there by represent Paul Ryan
the chairman at the time with the budget
committee this should be a place where
important public figures come to give
important statements about the larger
things and the space itself is beautiful
which lends itself to good conversation
we had a great conversation today among
about 40 members of the Republican Study
Committee which is the conservative
caucus of House Republicans setting
their agenda their vision and their
strategy for the upcoming Congress and
what a beautiful place here at the Kirby
Center to do that
and so the Kirby Center is this
incredible presence where he'll still
standing up and saying we want to engage
we want to engage other politicians and
we want to engage the American people
here reform this country so it's really
exciting to see Hillsdale step up and
take a stand with the Kirby Center
you